à halloween cette fête typiquement
française alors halloween moi je trouve
qu est ce qui est la chose
ah oui on vient de passer la barre des
11 millions d'abonnés sur ma chaîne
youtube donc déjà merci à tous alors
halloween
moi j'adore chaque année c'est vraiment
l'occasion de se faire gentiment peur
entre potes d'église avec des petits
costumes des familles voilà c'est le
folklore tout le monde fêtent halloween
mais on sait pas trop d'où elle vient
cette fête alors en fête halloween est
une fête païenne traditionnel originaire
des îles anglo celte way pour le chien
chien hyper chiant opim merde c'est une
excuse pour se bourrer la gueule
pour faire court halloween c'est une
fête d'origine celte qui s'est
introduite en amérique du nord après une
vague d'immigration
d'ailleurs pour l'anecdote hockey
toi bien
d'ailleurs pour l'anecdote à l'époque
ont sculpté pas des citrouilles mais des
bons gros navets comme dans le contient
landais jack à la lanterne
et puis les américains ont remplacé les
navets par des citrouilles parce que
parce que c'était de la merde en fait
alors moi quand j'étais petit il n'y
avait pas halloween en france ça
n'existait pas la france opposée
totalement à cette fête non halloween
ce ne sont pas de valeur et puis
finalement un jour là la magie a opéré
vous savez qu'à darwin peuvent apporter
plusieurs millions de dollars par an
ce sont nos valeurs jveux des
citrouilles
alors j'ai appris selon wikipedia qu'on
peut aussi dire l l'halloween
et qui dit ça en fait moi je fête
l'halloween tout comme la pac et la noël
avec ma femme
1 à corinne et maintenant quelques
astuces pour une soirée de l'halloween
de qualité sculpter une citrouille en
suivant un tuto sur youtube une fois
terminé il vous reste plus qu'à la jetée
et en acheter une déjà tout fait
accrocher à votre maison cette fameuse
toile d'araignée de merde qui va rester
toute l'année
réunissez tous vos bonbons dégueulasse
ou périmés pour les redistribuer décorer
votre maison avec des trucs bien
flippant et bas dans cette année comme
décoration effrayante jacques rocher une
photo de mon ex
avec son nouveau mec bordel qu'est ce
qu'ils s'aiment et mon avis d'imposition
en fait ça me fait toujours un petit
quelque chose
accueillez vous invitez votre soirée
déguisée et comme tous les ans sans
surprise un on aura le costume hyper
original bah quoi je me reconnais pas
charlie queen le mec pas déguiser et qui
fait toujours la même blague je désire
même pas déguiser celui ou celle qui a
pas trop compris le concept de faire
peur
ab alors je suis là je suis terrorisée
le mec qui a voulu faire une référence
trop poussé en fait chaque billet en
résistant normand de la fin de la
seconde guerre mondiale enfin des me 45
une période riche en péripéties
celui qui est pas très doué en travaux
manuels
turenne pas le costume qu'on a du mal à
comprendre en fait un mélange de deux
clowns magnum est un épouvantail de
hawaï au pied au final chacun son style
un bonjour jean séry témoins de jéhovah
je suis là pour répandre la parole du
christ et du seigneur ah ouais le
costume hyper original bien ouej dont je
suis sérieux c'est vraiment là pour
insein il ya des biens dans le frigo tu
me la raconter vous des petites
histoires effrayantes et donc la toto
dit bah c'était pas une saucisse c'était
ma job qu'ils soient pas peur ouais
c'était pas une saucisse 7 le mode
regarder un film d'horreur à plusieurs
avec plein de bons screamer oil
escrimeurs c'est parce que c'est bas
monte un peu le son allez-y ventes
montent elles sont passées ça y est
désolé c'est le concept d'ailleurs ça
marche uniquement parce qu'elles sont
bien flippant avec un autre son ca fait
pas le même effet quoique en fait
l'image aussi doit être flippante 1
parce que si on n'est pas la bonne basse
nul à temps mais c'est à dire n'importe
quoi c'est screamer là et puis pour
finir baham et bourré vous bien avec
gueule h d'horloge une [ __ ] les
enfants volés d'un coq ou pas
merci à tous d'avoir suivi cette vidéo
oui
bon bon ça bah désolé je tourne des
vidéos en fait là je suis occupé pas mal
d'effets en tout cas je voyais je suis
occupé j'ai pas le temps puis en plus
j'ai pas de bonbons en fait
ok c'était quoi ce délire
waouh qu'est ce qui se passe à attend
avec c'est bizarre on est con marche
pour la caméra non plus elle est bloquée
sur enregistrer on dirait le début d'un
mauvais film d'horreur prenons quoi au
nom coiffer un film d'horreur chinois je
vais mourir au début non mais qu on est
plus fort que ça on est soudés on va
prouver au reste du monde qu'on est plus
puissant que les clichés hollywoodiens
choteau du gouvernement gilbert
[Musique]
je rêve ou le placard bouge tout seul
mec sur moulins ouvrent
tu vois c'était un chat mais que j'en
étais sûr des stress tout va bien norman
norman joyeuses fêtes
oui
[Musique]